good evening
i'm laura welcher from the long now
foundation i'm the director of the
rosetta project
and uh as some of you may know
this summer we finished our first
prototype rosetta disk
after eight years of work
and
and so now five copies of that disc are
out there in the world uh that is the
very long term
archive of the rosetta project which is
uh as as you know is a collection of the
world's languages and when we made that
available and over the past several
years we've had many many requests
for a version that
wouldn't cost twenty five thousand
dollars
and uh
and that we could distribute it very
widely
so um i'm very pleased to announce that
we have now
made a version that can be distributed
very widely
and this is a
digital fully browsable version of the
disc
which is available now on dvd and today
we've made it available on the rosetta
project website for anybody to go and
interact with
and so this is what it looks like so now
if you go to
rosettaproject.org this is what you see
and this gives you the virtual
experience of looking at the rosetta
disc through a microscope except you
browsing it on your computer
and uh so what you see here is the
what we call the human eye readable side
so this is the part that starts with
languages at a scale that the human eye
can see and it tells you this is an
archive of the world's languages and
then this the the text spirals down and
gets progressively smaller and smaller
and inside those
radiating spokes are lists
are a list of languages
that have information on the other side
of the disk so
i'll
show you what this looks like
you can browse all the way in
the languages are arranged by geographic
region
and so you can see i'm zooming in on the
americas
and getting closer
closer
and here you can see
we have a documentation in the rosetta
project on
the piraha language that dan everett is
going to be talking about tonight so
there's uh
mura piraha which is the um the very
small language grouping that peterhot
belongs to
and
you can also look at the other side of
the disk this is um the archive side so
this side has
about 14 000 pages of documentation
on about 1 500 languages there's about 7
000 languages in the world so this is a
good chunk of them
and you can also zoom all the way in on
this one
so now we're zooming into the region
that has documentation on languages of
the americas
and getting closer and closer
and closer
aha
turns out we have information on bitter
hot
by
daniel everett
so uh you're very welcome to to go
browse the site at your leisure you can
also buy dvd versions of
of this disk